الملف الاوكراني كان حاضرا بقوه على طاوله
مباحثات الرئيسين الصيني والفرنسي في
العاصمه ايمانويل ماكرون نشد نظيره
باعاده روسيا الى رشدها والمساعده في
تحقيق السلام دائم في اوكرانيا الرئيس
الفرنسي اشار الى دعم الصين لميثاق الامم
المتحده الذي يدعو الى احترامي وحده اراضي
الدول مضيفا ان غزو الرئيس الروسي
لاوكرانيا يهدد السلام والاستقرار
القائمين على المبادئ الدوليه الصين من
جانبها كانت اعلنت عن صداقه بلا حدود مع
روسيا قبل بدء الحرب في اوكرانيا الا انها
اعلنت التزامها الحياد ودعت الى عقد
محادثه السلام وكان الرئيس الصيني اعرب عن
استعداد بيكين لتعزيز الحوار السلمي
والتسويه السياسيه بالتعاون مع فرنسا
لدعوه المجتمع الدولي الى الحفاظ على ضبط
النفس في سياق الازمه الاوكرانيه
من الواضح ان الحديث عن الامن والاستقرار
يعني الحديث عن الحرب التي تشنها روسيا
على اوكرانيا هذه الحرب انهت عقودا من
السلام على الاراضي الاوروبيه لكنها حرب
الجميع لان احد اعضاء الامن في الامم
المتحده انتهاك الميثاق وهذا غير مقبول
الرئيس الفرنسي طلب ايضا من نظيره الصيني
الضغط على روسيا للامتثال للقواعد الدوليه
المتعلقه بالحد من نشر الاسلحه النوويه
الطلب الفرنسيه ياتي بعد اعلان الرئيس
الروسي فلاديمير بوتين في الخامس والعشرين
من الشهر الماضي انه سينشر اسلحه نوويه
تكتيكيه في روسيا البيضاء جارت اوكرانيا
من جانبه قال الرئيس الصيني انه ينبغي على
جميع الدول احترام الحد من نشر الاسلحه
النوويه وعدم شن حرب نوويه من دون ان يذكر
الرئيس الصيني روسيا بشكل صريح وبحسب
الرئيس الصيني ستدعو بكين وباريس جميع
الدول الى منع استخدام الاسلحه النوويه
والبيولوجيه والكيميائيه وكذلك معارضه
مهاجمه محطات الطاقه النوويه والمنشات
النوويه المدنيه الاخرى
النقطه الثانيه التي قدمتها بقوه هي
الجديه والشعور بالامان فيما يتعلق
بالقضايا النوويه فرنسا تريد التاكد من
استبعاد الطاقه النوويه من هذا الصراع
ويجب احترام المعاهدات الدوليه ولا يمكن
باي حال من الاحوال نشر الاسلحه النوويه
خاصه في اوروبا وفي هذا الصدد يجب تذكير
الجميع بواجباتهم وخاصه روسيا التي اعلنت
قبل ايام قليله رغبتها في نشر اسلحه
النوويه في بيلاروسيا هذا يتعارض مع
التزاماتنا والقانون
وفيما يخص علاقات الصين مع الاتحاد
الاوروبي قال الرئيس الصيني ان بلاده
مستعد للعمل مع التكتل الاوروبي لاستئناف
التعاوني على جميع المستويات ولضخ قوه دفع
جديده في العلاقات بين الجانبين واضاف
الرئيس الصيني انه يتعين على الصين
والاتحاد الاوروبي الالتزام بالحوار
والتعاون والحفاظ على السلامه والاستقرار
العالميين وتعزيز التنميه والازدهار
المشتركين جانبها قالت رئيسه المفوضيه
الاوروبيه ارسل فانظر ان الاتحاد الاوروبي
والصين شريكان تجاريان ويجب ان يتعاون
لمواجهه كافه التحديات العالميه